僕が愛と出会ったのはちょうど10年前に
なります
その当時東京でサラリーマンをしていたん
ですけど
毎日忙しくて
ほんと会社と寮の往復ばかりで
ほとんど休みもなくて
そんな中もうせっかくできたやすみ絶対
これはしておきたいということでやりたい
ことノートっていうのをつけはじめたのが
本当最初のきっかけになります
a
その休みの日が本当つけた直後ぐらいに
すぐ来て
で見返して最初の1行目パッと見たら
藍染っていうワードが書いてあって藍染
カーでそこから東京大爪できる工房さんを
探し始めました
で東京の西の方に
めぼしい工房が1件見つかりまして
よしここに行こっということで
朝早くから電車に乗ってホント楽しみ半分
不安半分で
向かったのを今でも鮮明に覚えています
工房に着くと
職人下がって迎えてくれたんですけどその
職人さん体がもう真っ青で
さらに後方の中に進めば進むにつれて
愛の臭いがすごいしてきて
初めての経験だったのですごいテンション
が上がって
そこから無我夢中で体験したっていうのを
すごく覚えてます
でいざ染色ってなった時に
木イチョウ
サラリーマンで営業職だったのでてが多く
なると困るんじゃないですかってね手袋
渡されたんですけど
ちょっと食い気味にやちょっといいです
それで弾きますというふうに応えて素手で
染めさせてもらう
うように
なりまして
で実際こう染色液に手を浸した時に本当に
言葉ではこう言い表せないくれ雷に打たれ
たような
感覚に陥りまして
それと同時に
生まれてきたのは愛をしなきゃいけないん
じゃないかっていうちょっとした使命感も
すごく覚えるようになって
染色したぷに
またその染色した布水でさらうんですけど
またそこでも綺麗な桜が出てきて
こんなに心を揺さぶるような経験をし
たっていう本当に初めて
だったんですよ
そこから本当に会いにとりつかれちゃい
ましたね
どうも体験した色は
た出会いという植物の簡素葉を発酵させて
作っもという線量をつくって
その宿毛またさらに発酵させて染色液に
仕込んだものらしく
日本古来からある日本督促のもの藍色で
あるということが分かりました
このスク文を製造している一大産地が徳島
県っていうことがわかったんですけど端
さらにこの愛の業界自体が後継者が本当
少なくなって先細りしいる業界ということ
も一緒にわかったんです
これはこんなに素敵な教会なのに無くなっ
ちゃうなんてもったいないと思っ
どうしてもその愛に携わりたくなる気持ち
が日に日に募ってって
体験してから4日後には
辞表提出しちゃってたんですねちょっと今
思うとずっとしちゃうんですけど
その中で
愛を学べる先を調べていたところこの徳島
県の上板町というところで募集している
地域おこし協力隊って言う
その募集を見つけたんですよ
でその内容がその藍産業の次世代の担い手
とその pr をしてほしいっていう内容
ですぐ問い合わせをかけたんですね着任し
てから1年間は研修に出てもらいますって
いうふうに担当の方に言われたんですけど
その研修先が
なんとその僕が初めて体験した藍染工房で
使われている
スクもうの占領を作っている場所だったん
ですよ
うわこれは
と思って本当に運命すら感じて
で
ここに行けるなと思っ
応募して
そこからトントン拍子に受かって
で気づいたら染色を体験してから4カ月後
に特殊間に
行くことが決まっていて
ようやくそこから僕の愛人生がスタート
することになりました
[拍手]
当時から愛業界は分業制になっていました
た出会いを栽培して
宿毛製造する愛しさんっていう職業とその
愛しさんから宿毛を購入して染色液を
仕込んで様々な染色技法で染めを行う染め
師さんっていうのに大きく分かれてか
で徳島県だけでも染め師さんはたくさん
いるんですけど
愛しさんとなると保険しかいないような
状態だったんですね
で販売価格もその労働の労力に見合わない
価格っていうのもあって
新規参入するような人も全然いない状態で
でその当時まだ
宿毛自体は i さんから購入する事は
出来た状態だったんですけど
明らかにこの先この宿毛の供給が追いつか
なくなって手に入らなくなる
時が来るんだなっていうのは目に見えて
分かっているような状態だったんですよ
この問題を打破するためには今までこう
分業化されてた愛しと染め師という職業
両方こなすしか選択肢がなかったんです
ただ
前例がなかったので当然周りからは否定的
な意見ばかり
言われました
でもそんな中思ったんです
何もないということは何でもアリってこと
むしろ自分で栽培からつくも作って染色
まで行えるということは
自分自身の色を作れるわけなので唯一無二
の色で制作活動ができるというふうに思っ
たんですよ
当然全行程に対して自分で向き合うことで
責任もしっかり取れるし
一つ一つの作業に対して思いを持って
取り組めるなーっていうのもすごい思った
んです
その自分で取り組んで作ったりロガー
暮らしになじんで
何百らも残ってほしいっていう思いが
すごい
なんだ強く思うようになったんですよ
まず取りかかりにこの教会の凝り固まった
何ですかね暗黙の了解とか
海外へ向けて発信していくとかちょっと
閉鎖的な部分を
いろいろ壊していこうというふうに思い
始めたんですよ
でまたそうやって新しいグルーしようと
する旅
無理だとか
辞めた理由とかという否定的な意見がまた
てるんですけど
もう2回目なんもうその時にはむしろ子
言われた方が
所やってやるぞという気持ちにもなるし
だんだんこう面白くなって知っ
いるような状態でした
旦那と活動していくにつれてその活動に
共感して面白いと思って発信してくれる人
も徐々に増えてきたし
そんな状況の中で
ちょっと海外でニューヨークで藍染めの
ワークショップやってみないかなんて声も
かけていただいたこともあって
果たして日本のこの宿毛発行していきを
つくって染めるっていう独特のその技法が
どこまで海外で受け入れてもらえるのかな
っていうのが
すごく疑問で不安な部分でもあったんです
ただ
やっぱり協会的に国内でもちょっと動き
づらさを感じていた時期でもあったんで
いやこれはぜひ挑戦したいっていう思いの
方が強かったですよ
って実際そのニューヨークに行って
藍染のわーくしょっく
開催してきたわけなんですけど
もう思った以上に反応がやっぱりすごくて
で
日本だったら綺麗ですねとかちょっと
控えめなんですけどやっぱ海外でやると
そのリアクションがで行
お前がお前がお前がみたいなすごいいい
リアクションって
こっちも嬉しくなるしあとはその
刷毛から
色まで作ってそのプロセスに対してすごく
その思いをくんでくれた
そのやっぱり
意見がすごい嬉しく
やっぱり自信になりましたね
で無効だとやっぱりいろんなアーティスト
さんとか
いろんなご職業の方とかいろんな珍種の形
で
お会いする機会だったり話しする機会と
いうのはたくさんあって
今まで日本でしか活動しなかった僕にとっ
てはいろんな人と
意見交換したり話しできたりそういうこと
ができて
やっぱりすごくこれからものぞくいして
いくのにい刺激になったような時期でも
あります
自分たちの活動の中で国内外
通して展示だったりワークショップデー
どんどんと活動を積極的に行うにつれて
自分たちはその藍色っていうのが
すごく広まってきているしやっぱり認知度
も上がってきているなっていう実感は
すごい感じてました
ただ一方で
さて動き回ると忙しくなる部分もあったり
あとはその会社顔して人手を増やしたりし
たこともあって
やっぱり現場から貼られる時間っていうの
はすごく増えたんですよ
で
現場の最前線で体を動かして自然とか微
生物と対話をしながら色を作るっていう
ことが本当できなくなってきていて
そこにすごく違和感を覚えたりしていまし
たね
でだんだんとその
なんというかこう
花も伸びてたんでしょうかね高調子に乗っ
て言ったじゃないですけど
地域の人とか今まで応援してくれた人に
あれはなんだかこう白々しくなっちゃった
ねーとか遠くに感じちゃうわねーっていう
風に言われたりもして
なんか今思えば本当に
その謙虚さとか感謝とかそういう気持ちも
当たり前のことなんだけどそういうのも
なく定款
思うことが低下してたんだよう
そういうのはすごく感じました
で
やっぱりそういう思いが重なっていくと
本当に大事にしたり自分の中で大事にして
思っていうかどんどんどんどん
やっぱり再認識していくようになって
そこで断腸の思いであるんですけど
その解消をやめて
またゼロから
再出発しようっていう風に
決心して会社を抜けました
でまた新たに
自分の思いに沿った会社をこそ色作りして
いこうという中で
またゼロから
1を作ってまた一から中に育てていくって
いう活動しなきゃいけなくなるんですけど
またその中でやっぱり一人では
できないことたくさんある日
またそういう思いに戻ってきたからこそ
応援支部れる地域だし
仲間だったり
っていう人が力を貸してくれて
でようやく
思うような形で
活動が出来るような体制
できたんですけど
やっぱりリアラためて
いろんな人に
謙虚さを忘れるなとか
初診忘れるべからずとか感謝しなさいあっ
て増とちっちゃい頃から言われてきたん
ですけど
やっぱりそういうところが
何かのきっかけでご失念するじゃねぇ
それをまた30過ぎても
痛感したというのは30過ぎてようやく
わかったような感じで自分が高野台に
関われているのも
いろんな人を応援してくれる人だったり
ずっと支えてくれる人がたくさんいるから
僕はこういう思いで愛に取り組んでいける
んだなっていうふうな環境があるっていう
風なのつくづく思って
深く反省しました
改めてアイルを探求していく中で
たどり着いたのはやっぱり農業の部分でし
た
土づくりだったり栽培する過程っていう
ものがやっぱり藍色の色が始まる
スタートだなっていうのが
やっぱり今一度再認識したんです
ってもちろん毎回栽培する葉っぱっていう
ものは天候にもよるし
いろんな長兼かで
出来不出来が変わってくるんですけど
当然それを材料にして作る宿毛っていうの
は
大きく
材料に影響されるじゃないですかなので
宿毛っていう結果色としての結果を見る
よりもまずはその前の
すくも作り
農業の部分にしっかりとフォーカスして
その過程を
しっかりやっていくことで
いい色につながるいう風に考えたんですね
毎年大変な作業だとはわかってはいるん
ですけども
やっぱり環境なので同じ環境というのは
自然とか微生物もっ
訪れることはなくて
全く違う環境に毎年なるのでそれがすごく
新鮮で楽しみでもあります
自分が描いた夢に向かって
挑戦していく過程でやっぱり幾多の障壁
っていうのは多く訪れると思うんですけど
その壁の声方っていうのは本当に行く通り
でもあるんじゃないかなというふうに思う
んですね
まあその所ばに言いましたけど何もないっ
ていうのは
なんでもあり
ことだと思う
でやっぱり
もう一個思うのは謙虚さとか感謝とか
初心を忘れるべからず
人生毎年一年生
そういう当たり前のことを羅列していくと
本当はちっちゃいものをついてるから
父ちゃんとかカーちゃう
作言われてきたような
当たり前のことっ
本当に退治だ
つくづく本当に身にしみて
感じます
で自分自身もまだまだ州の夢の途中
て
あるので
この教訓を胸に刻んで
[音楽]
忘れずにこれからも活動していきたいって
いう風に考えています
その中で生まれた愛が人々の生活に根付き
自分が死んでも残るものになっていって
ほしいと思います